let's go back to our new classics on a
classic when you guys were competing and
the whole controversy happened with
coronavirus how was that handle when you
were going I know about quarter of a
million people I couldn't go to the expo
there was some people that were partners
how was that frenzy when you're in it
what were you guys experiencing we
didn't I mean we were pretty much in our
own element as usual because you know
normally I'm in my room the whole time
anyway when I'm competing I don't go to
the expo anyway you know know back in
the day I used to when I worked for
muscle tech and stuff we had to go there
for hour and a half or something like
that but as I got older and don't have a
sponsor nutrition company anymore yeah I
don't go to an Expos in him anymore
anyway so that didn't affect me at all I
think for for the people I mean because
it's a sad situation I can understand
exactly where both parties are you know
coming from you know especially Arnold
because this show has been going on so
long and Plus you know he's I mean it's
the biggest thing in Ohio it's the
biggest event in Ohio and for them to
shut it down
it was pretty you know without even I
think from what I've heard I'm not going
to position but this is just what I
heard they shut it down without even
consulting him first you know the news
conference and he make all Arnold why
they had the news conference while I was
giving the conference so that was pretty
much a slap in the face but if things
were doing done the right way I can
understand where the government was
coming from as well you know our thing
is you still got Cavalier games that's
got 30,000 people 20,000 people at the
game and that's still going on well in
our event we still had our fans that
night but I could see where they're
coming from because 20,000 versus
250,000 that's a that's a big difference
and then I was Expo
it's all about touching man you touching
then you bumping there touching
everybody your kind of control when you
got your own seats you know so that's
why I figured they let us have our
normal night show with everybody because
it's controlled they already bought
these seats and they know where
everybody's at and it's not like other
people are still coming in you know what
I'm saying like Expo expose the ending
out people coming from everywhere all
over the work just that's one thing our
people understand these people coming
from all over the world when you got an
NBA game those people probably just
right from clear eyed unless if it's a
playoff championship game the season
game it's local people absolutely in the
honor class it gets people coming from
all over the world you know so they can
be carrying anything that makes sense
that's not they haven't been I know
people that has gone some of my friends
that I've gone to the Arnold they got
sick every year that's before the corona
virus that's sick
every year they come go back home they
sick or something you know I'm saying so
I can understand what both parties it
was just a sad situation that it had to
go down you know now that this whole
virus thing is going down man it's sad
for everybody that's involved you know
what I'm saying
you
[Music]